La bikelife,
c'est : on kiffe et voilà, hein...
Liberté, ouais.
Salut à tous, c’est Yagmur
et dans cette vidéo, j'ai eu envie
de vous raconter les coulisses
d'un documentaire que j'ai
adoré tourner et qui s'appelle Bikelife.
Depuis la diffusion
de Bikelife sur BrutX,
beaucoup de choses
ont changé dans la vie de Junior,
celui qui m'a ouvert
les portes de cet univers.
La bikelife, c’est pas
une petite passion qui dure
un ou deux mois, c'est vraiment...
soit tu l’es vraiment à 100%,
soit tu l’es pas.
Après la diffusion du docu,
Junior a passé un casting pour un film
et il a obtenu le deuxième rôle secondaire
dans le film Rodeo de Lola Quivoron,
qui est sélectionné au Festival de Cannes.
- Vous faites quoi, ici ?
Vous retapez les bécanes,
vous replaquez les numéros.
- Vas-y, bouge de là !
Bouge, je t’ai dit !
C’est elle, la nouvelle
poule aux œufs d’or, les gars.
Bikelife, on l’avait tourné
en septembre 2020
et ce n'était pas de tout repos.
Je vous laisse découvrir les coulisses.
Ça fait plusieurs années
que je filme dans les quartiers
et je croise souvent
des mecs avec des cross.
Je me suis jamais posé la question
vraiment de ce que faisaient
ces motocross en pleine ville
et je me suis dit que ce docu,
ce serait l'occasion
de savoir qui ils sont, de les rencontrer
et de leur donner la parole.
J'ai commencé à faire plein de recherches
sur Internet, j'ai lu des articles,
j'ai regardé des reportages
sur le rodéo urbain.
En fait, ce qui revenait le plus souvent,
c'est que c'est une pratique dangereuse,
c'est des délinquants, c'est
des mecs de cité qui font n'importe quoi.
On a notre propre code de la route.
On sait que quand il y a
quelqu'un devant qui lève
et qui fait des zigzags, tu vois,
faut pas passer devant lui, tout ça.
On a... on a une manière
de rouler, tu vois ?
D’un œil extérieur,
ça paraît dangereux, c'est vrai,
mais on sait ce qu'on fait, tu vois ?
Tous les gens dans toutes les zones,
on se réunit tous
et, en fait, on fait
de la moto ensemble, tu vois ?
On oublie les problèmes, on oublie tout.
Moi, en fait, c'est ces mecs
passionnés de motocross
que j'avais envie d'entendre.
Dès le début, en fait,
quand je suis allée voir ces bikers,
ils m’ont tout de suite
parlé de passion
et c'est ce kiff, en fait, que je voulais
comprendre à travers ce docu.
C'est comme ça
que j'entre en contact avec Junior,
et quand je le rencontre
pour la première fois,
il me donne rendez-vous
dans un fast-food à Nanterre
et c'est lui qui m’ouvre
les portes de l'univers de la bikelife.
Et pendant 2 heures, Junior, il me fait
des déclarations d'amour pour sa moto.
Vraiment, là, c'est comme
si j'étais avec ma meuf, tout...
C'est de l'amour, clairement,
c'est de l'amour.
Une petite copine,
tant qu'il y a la moto, c'est mort.
Et grâce à Junior, en fait,
j'ai compris que la bikelife,
c'est beaucoup plus
qu'une  aprem' entre potes.
Lui, ce qu'il recherche, c'est
une vraie sensation de liberté.
Quand il est sur la moto, il me dit
qu'il oublie tous ses problèmes.
C’est ça, là.
C’est ça, la bikelife.
On se retrouve entre amis,
on est là, on...
On a la même passion,
on fait des roues.
Bah, c'est ça, la bikelife.
- Tu sais comment y aller ?
En fait, ce qui a été le plus compliqué,
ce qui a pris le plus de temps,
c'est de gagner leur confiance.
Parce que quand je leur ai...
quand je me suis présentée,
beaucoup m'ont dit
qu'ils se sentaient caricaturés
dans les reportages qui ont déjà été faits
sur les rodéos urbains,
et donc c'était un vrai travail,
ce n'était pas simple, en fait, d'arriver
dans leur univers juste avec ma caméra.
Il fallait d'abord
que je montre patte blanche et que...
et qu'en fait, ils apprennent
à me connaître et à me faire confiance.
Ce qui m'a frappée, en fait,
la première fois que je les ai rencontrés,
près d'Aulnay-sous-Bois,
c'est qu'ils viennent tous de quartiers
différents de la région parisienne
et que quand ils sont ensemble, sur
la moto, toutes les frontières s'effacent.
On est à Aulnay, Garonor,
on se retrouve là le week-end,
des mecs de partout :
91, 92, 95, 77, 93...
Partout.
Donc, après notre rencontre,
j’ai Junior au téléphone,
il me dit : “Viens, on sort en barode.”
Et je lui dis :
“Mais c'est quoi une barode, en fait ?
Je comprends rien.”
Et c'est le mot qu'utilisent les bikers
pour parler des sorties
à moto sur le périph',
ce qu'on appelle les rodéos, quoi.
D'abord, j'avais peur
de me casser  la gueule à moto
et ensuite, j'avais peur
de me retrouver embarquée
dans une course poursuite
avec la police sur le périph'.
Il faut savoir que c'est une pratique
qui est interdite en ville, c'est illégal,
et ceux qui pratiquent le rodéo urbain
risquent une peine de prison,
une amende ou encore
la confiscation de leur moto.
D'ailleurs, Junior est
pas passé loin de tout ça,
mais je vous en parlerai
un peu plus tard.
Éteins ça !
Alors, la première fois
que je suis sur la moto,
c'est vrai que je suis pas super à l'aise,
je suis pas stable du tout.
J'ai un casque qui est
trop grand pour ma tête,
donc, en fait, j'y vois que dalle
et je pense que ça se voit sur les images.
Mes réglages partent
complétement en vrille.
Enfin, je filme n'importe quoi.
Là, ça fait plusieurs semaines
que je suis Junior et ses potes
et en fait, je me rends compte
que la plupart du temps,
ils se retrouvent sur une piste
de moto école
où ils sont à peu près tranquilles.
Et, c'est surtout là
qu'ils se retrouvent, en fait,
pour faire de la moto
ou alors juste se poser entre potes.
En fait, Junior, à chaque
fois que je le retrouve,
il a tout le temps de
nouveaux trous dans son jean
parce qu'il passe son temps
à se casser la gueule.
Mais, à chaque fois,
il remonte sur sa moto et il repart.
Bref, il faut que
je vous raconte une petite anecdote :
quand je tournais
une barode avec Junior et ses potes,
j'avais pris un peu d'avance
avec un de ses amis
et là, je vois un mouvement de panique.
Tout le monde fait demi-tour
et je commence à être hyper inquiète
parce que je comprends
que quelqu'un est tombé et en arrivant,
je me rends compte
que c'est Junior qui est à terre.
Donc j'ai vraiment peur,
mais là, je le vois se relever.
Il remonte sur sa moto
et il repart à toute vitesse.
J'ai déséquilibré, ça m'a emmené
sur le trottoir et... enfin...
C'est des choses qui arrivent.
Ça va, j'ai rien eu !
Juste ça...
Wallah, attends !
Qu'est-ce que t'as fait ?
Vas-y, ça me fout la rage !
Y a un truc de tordu...
L'allu, c'est tout.
Non, le guidon, il est pas touché.
Quand on se retrouve
sur la piste de moto-école,
on parle vite des accidents
qui arrivent à moto
et Junior me parle d'Ibo.
C'est un de ses potes
qui devait le rejoindre le 6 octobre 2019.
Il me raconte son histoire.
Ce jour-là, on doit se rejoindre
pour se rassembler et faire de la moto,
kiffer toute une après-midi.
Et donc nous, on est déjà là-bas,
on fait de la moto, on kiffe, on l'attend.
Ça va bien se passer,
on dirait, hein.
Là, personne peut dire
j'ai pas de casque.
- Normal !
- La bonne sécu.
Quand je réalise ce documentaire,
je me dis que je peux pas raconter
la bikelife sans parler
de l'histoire d'Ibo.
Et c'est comme ça que je rencontre
pour la première fois son frère.
Ibo, quand il était tout petit,
je l'amenais déjà à Paris faire du vélo.
Il faisait déjà des levées de roues en vélo
au Trocadéro, au Champ-de-Mars,
près de la tour Eiffel.
La première fois que je les rencontre,
c'est à Sarcelles, c'est là où Ibo a grandi.
On se donne rendez-vous dans un local.
Y a sa sœur, ses frères, y a des amis,
y a des membres du collectif.
En fait, ce jour-là, c'était un moment
très émouvant de ce doc
parce qu'ils étaient en train
d'organiser une marche pour Ibo.
Y avait tous les amis, la famille
qui fabriquaient des pancartes
et qui organisaient le défilé.
Là, on arrive au niveau du stand,
que tu vois juste ici.
Ibo, il est devant moi, y a un véhicule
qui s'intercale entre nous deux, tu vois.
Du coup, au niveau du stop,
on prend à droite
et y a un véhicule entre lui et moi.
Celui qui me raconte l'histoire d'Ibo,
c'est Samir, un autre de ses potes.
Ce jour-là, ils se rendent ensemble
sur la piste de moto-école.
Le camion de police, il était là,
il fait un mouvement sec,
un coup de volant,
et au moment où on arrive ici,
je pense le camion de police,
il a voulu bloquer la route,
tu vois, pour pas que
le cross, il puisse passer.
Du coup, il s'est décalé
et il est arrivé
clairement
sur notre voie, tu vois.
Je suis arrivé à Villiers-le-Bel,
je le voyais allongé et...
pas de traces sur le visage,
un drap blanc sur lui.
Ils l'ont cartonné !
Ils l'ont tué, ces bâtards !
Le corps, ils l'ont tué, wallah !
Ça a été très dur pour Samir
de revenir sur les lieux.
Sur place, il y avait plusieurs caméras
de vidéosurveillance et depuis deux ans,
en fait, la famille se bat
pour avoir un accès à ces vidéos,
pour comprendre
ce qui s'est passé ce jour-là.
Quand je me suis rendue
à l'hommage pour Ibo,
c'est vrai que c'était
très émouvant parce que,
à un moment, j'ai vu arriver
toutes les motos d'un coup,
ça grondait de partout
et c'est vraiment là que j'ai ressenti
la solidarité qu'ils avaient entre eux
et j'ai vraiment compris
que c'était une famille, en fait,
la famille des bikeurs.
- Téma l'arrivée des bikeurs !
Pour notre frère Ibo et
pour toutes les familles,
pour tous les défunts,
on va prier fort.
Je vous ai dit au début de cette
vidéo que c'était un tournage
qui était très mouvementé
et que tout pouvait arriver.
Après l'hommage, les bikeurs quittent
Sarcelles et là, une course poursuite
s'engage avec les motards de police.
Sur la vidéo, le bikeur que
vous voyez en jaune, c'est Junior.
En fait, il se rabat sur le trottoir
pour esquiver la police
et il se fait arrêter.
Après cette vidéo,
j'ai plus de nouvelles de lui
pendant 24 heures, donc je décide
de contacter sa famille
qui me dit qu'il est dans
un commissariat à Bobigny.
On était en garde-à-vue
pendant 30 heures.
C'est même pas
pour un rodéo, frère.
Un hommage, c'est pas
une barode qu'on s'est dit
"on va faire, on va aller
chercher la police", non.
C'était organisé, y avait un départ
et ils nous attendaient dans la ville
d'à côté, ils nous attendaient.
Ils attendaient,
ils ont lâché les motards sur nous.
Je me rends à son audience.
Finalement, il s'en sort
avec cinq mois de prison avec sursis,
la confiscation de sa moto
et une amende.
Vas-y, bah... on s'appelle.
J'ai quitté Junior juste après
son jugement et aujourd'hui,
il va monter les marches
du Palais des Festivals à Cannes.
Et je suis hyper contente qu'il puisse
continuer à vivre sa passion.
Il a aussi réalisé le rêve
dont il me parlait tout le temps,
celui de faire
de la bécane aux États-Unis.
C'est là où la bikelife est née.
Je vous mets quelques extraits
de son trip à Miami.
Let's go !
Téma, wesh !
La tête de ma mère,
on est trop.
Ça arrache tout !
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'hésitez pas
à me faire des retours en commentaires,
je les lirai.
Et si vous voulez voir Bikelife,
c'est disponible sur BrutX.
Moi, je vous dis à bientôt.